[Music]
so welcome good morning good afternoon
good evening for the folks on the
livestream my name is Beth Camden I am
part of the Google cloud team and I lead
our backup disaster recovery
partnerships so my role is to build a
deliberate data protection portfolio
strategy with our partners and our
eternal teams as well as a go-to market
for execution so a little fun fact about
me I actually jumped from a plane I did
skydiving my wife hated it
I actually didn't tell her I was gonna
do it until I did so I definitely need a
back-up plan you know and and just just
so notice it's called backup archive and
disaster recovery that's an acronym for
bad that I should probably change my
name and remove the e and it's just a
perfect match so awesome so welcome
everybody we're gonna get going here
we're gonna start with a little bit
about cloud a data protection and the
cloud opportunity and then go in then
talk about the partner landscape so we
have partnerships that we work with
industry-leading partnerships to drive
these solutions backup archiving D our
solutions we mark it then I'm going to
invite up on stage several partners and
customers to actually give you know any
examples of how these solutions are
actually practically in you know
leverage in GCP right now and we'll hear
from their experiences and their
journeys as they adopted Google cloud
and the partner solution for these
specific use cases it'll wrap it up
that's not like a plan
awesome awesome all right we'll get
going so we all know the data is growing
per IDC data is going to grow to 175
zettabytes by 2025 just to give us
context that is
a hundred and seventy-five billion
terabytes it's a lot of data four
hundred and forty percent growth of data
compared to last year's alone and what
is 175 comprised of 42 of that capacity
will be shipping over the next seven
years 90 zettabytes of the data will be
created by IOT devices by 2025 we've
heard about IOT devices and sensors
creating data that data is just part of
it and then by 2025 49 % of the data
will be stored in cloud in a public
cloud environment you know and and again
this is according to an IDC report that
was published in 2018 and nearly 30
percent of that data generated will be
consumed in real time by them so a huge
opportunity huge amounts of data being
generated and that will continue to
drive costs using traditional approaches
and we know the cloud market in general
is doubling over the next you know
several years the reality is only 5% of
that data has been generated so far has
been analyzed so imagine the potential
loss of revenue profitability and and
customer satisfaction that could have
been realized if organizations had you
know put that data to work and deriving
insights from it and accelerating time
decision in a time - so accelerating
this isn't tight in the decision time -
using those those insights and the last
piece here is the cloud given all this
opportunity the cloud backup market
according to market research future
report well is also expected to grow to
nearly 5.6 billion dollars and that is
driven by factors such as lower cost
greater efficiencies by leveraging cloud
backup versus on-premises backup
solution as well as the adoption of
South solutions and obviously the huge
amounts of data that's being derived so
what does that mean from your
perspective and data protection
with Google cloud first as you know
you've heard this week you know the
whole message is all about modernizing
your infrastructure leveraging the the
innovations that Google has that we've
made over the years and now we're
applying that and we're at we're looking
to extend that business continuity
strategy that you have built into Google
cloud specifically from a backup
perspective and that is backing up your
on-premises workloads to the cloud as
well as backing up your cloud workloads
and then archival for the data tier and
you know tier into different classes and
lastly disaster recovery so again
extending Google Cloud extending your
back your business continuity strategy
into Google cloud leveraging that you
know consistency that we have in our
storage classes we'll talk about that
here in a second to help reduce that
cost and and again take advantage of the
infrastructure that basically that runs
google.com search and email Gmail as
well as Maps
now we're extending that over and we're
applying that same capability that same
intelligence that same scale to two to
the backup and DRS base as well in
addition from a security perspective you
heard errors in his keynote yesterday
mentioned in a report the that Google
cloud was rated the highest rely had had
the highest reliability across any cloud
provider out there and that was not a
report that you know that we
commissioned that was a third-party
independent report and that speaks
volumes to the amount of security that
has built in that has been built in by
the Google engineers building up our
infrastructure to run our own business
and again extending that over to you
with encryption at you know of data at
rest as well as in motion and writing
once and reading many compliant storage
so that's an important aspect for the
highly regulated financial industries
and government public sector and you
know to be able to
you know alter that that data that's
been archived as well as kms and I am
you know integration is also available
in in storage and then the last piece
now that you've leveraged Google Cloud
to backup an hour kind of your data
you're now able to go and do more with
that data leverage those capabilities
that we have from an AI and ml
perspective to to achieve those desired
business outcomes as you as you saw on
the previous slide only 5% of the data
that has been generated is being
analyzed and actually being taken
advantage of this is an opportunity to
take it you know to utilize the
capabilities that are built in the
intelligence that is built in within
Google Cloud to derive those insights
and leverage you know the capabilities
that we have with the tipi use that we
have are 15 to 30% faster than
contemporary GPUs and CPUs out there so
I'm from a storage storage perspective
so as you're backing up and you're
archiving your data into storage how
many of you heard of the announcement
that we did yesterday around the archive
storage class all right is that what do
you guys think good awesome so it'll be
available later later this year
obviously but realize this is the
industry's first online archived here
online archive tier so it's not cold per
se it is cold storage but at the end of
the day it's available all right so as
you see here the price is going to start
at one dollar 23 per terabyte again
depending on your regions and locations
and there was a session yesterday
hopefully you guys attend that as well
around storage classes and that was
recorded we can you know you can go into
that a bit more but the main thing here
is again is across our all the storage
classes you have a unified experience
because we provide a single API for you
to integrate to our storage store - that
provides that consistent performance
across any of the storage classes
regardless of the hotness and coldness
of the class as well as you know the
guaranteeing that listing will always be
up to date so strongly consistent
listening
as well as a scalable again it's
scalable because of what we talked about
earlier is that planet-scale
infrastructure that we've built you sell
in one of the keynote so we started out
with two Eiffel Towers worth of steel
and now where was it 19 I think it was
and it's just beginning and we're
launched a couple route you know data
centers this week and you know a lot
more to come in the future
so with that we do like Simon earlier we
have partnerships that we've developed
you know over the time there are
industry leaders in the data protection
space and that covered different types
of use cases so the use cases again from
a backup perspective archive and D our
partners can have salute their solutions
provide you know you know solve problems
for you and and customers across these
different needs and again from a backup
perspective or differentiate between
backup of on-prem to cloud or close as
well as cloud were close in general and
that's across any cloud by the way again
back to that hybrid and and multi cloud
strategy we're taking that forward in
the partners are so working with us to
take that forward in addition we have
partnerships in the tape and hand
transfer arena so think about all your
tape data that you have how you go how
do you take that data and just sit back
into the cloud into the cloud so you
can't do what you need to do with it and
then how do you you know transfer that
so to give you context these are the
partnerships that we have we're very
keen to continue to grow the
partnerships to make sure that we're
meeting your needs I see a lot of
pictures by the way all of these slides
will be available to everyone feel free
to take pictures but they will be
available as well as they're recording
and my ask of all of you both customers
and partners in the room if there are
solutions
you know partners that you are working
with that are you know that aren't up
not up there please let us know submit a
you know question in the Dory and or
grab us a grab me afterwards and us chat
about
for a minute so with that let's hear
from our customers our partners what
we're gonna do is again talk about cloud
backup and we're gonna invite haiku who
is one of our backup as a service
partners as well as Nobu soft which is
gonna they're gonna bring a unique
perspective into today's conversation
because they're not just a customer but
they're also a Google cloud partner so
that you know they'll be able to provide
both of that the perspective as well as
the archival and backup of aam Prem
workload use case with Co he city and
Stanford medicine and last but not least
is to talk about the disaster recovery
use case and we'll invite up actifi oh
and a TB financial so with that let me
introduce and welcome on stage
Subbaiah from haiku and Santiago from
Nobu soft so so so by you've been in the
industry for a long time data protection
space welcome and Santiago you are the
co-founder of Nobu soft and the CTO and
congratulations on your win this week as
the Latin breakthrough partner of the
year so great job there take it away so
tell us a little bit about you know your
solution what's the you know what's the
benefit from a use case perspective for
the for the audience and then we'll hear
a little bit about the engagement from
your perspective
Thank You buzzer first off thank you
very much for inviting us can you guys
hear me yeah thank you very much for
inviting us to the show here first thing
let me tell you about our company itself
haiku we have been in business for over
20 plus years most people probably think
I've never heard of you because we used
to be in a different brand and we
rebranded ourselves about a year ago and
as a company
our focus is just data protection and
monitoring that's what we do we have
worked on at least eight different
backup products in the market today
so from engineering strength perspective
we have significant capabilities here we
have hundreds of engineers specifically
focused on data protection and that's
our core genesis of the company and I
think that's something we really pride
ourselves off
in some sense my sales guys sometime
take offense of this we have more
engineers than salespeople in our
company that's something which we do
because it's it's a strength for us
that's about the company itself let me
tell you about our focus as a company
our focus is to build purpose-built
solutions for every platform issues and
we are very happy that we chose Google
early on and I think he built a
purpose-built solution for Google so
that's I'll tell you more about the
solution itself but that's something we
chose because the reason is that we
believe Google is a excellent platform
for partners like us number one and for
great for you guys much better for you
guys actually so that's one of the
reason we chose it and we have actually
it's purpose-built for the solution for
that that's the second thing a third
thing I want to tell you about is our
world of product itself right the
product haiku for GCP it's a fully
managed service we introduced actually
it last July so it's been almost gonna
be nine plus months right now so we
introduced last July it's been in the
marketplace and we have had excellent
coverage from our customers customers
are very happy as well as some of our
partners we've been very happy with the
solution so you definitely hear from
robust off more about it so people ask
us so tell us about why purpose-built I
explicitly said it's a purpose-built
solution people tell me why purpose well
what's special about it right like the
key thing is the way we think about is
Google is a platform when you choose a
platform we believe backup and recovery
we should be an extended service of the
platform so that's why because when you
guys migrated your solutions or services
from your on-prem on the cloud you
wanted a cloud native solution that's
what you guys are looking for so let me
tell you a little bit about some of the
capabilities we offer and we'll
obviously be there later on to even
answer any question the first thing it's
a completely born in the cloud solution
even though as a company we have worked
on many many solutions right I mean I
Stoli we've been in business for a long
time and we had lots of IP we said then
we moved to the cloud we said we have to
build a cloud native solution because we
wanted you to have the Google cloud
experience
that's the
on a melting that's the first thing the
second thing people talk about scale
right and we see elastic scale and the
reason is that Google as a platform
that's one of the things they pride on
right it's the elastic scale nature
anytime you want to spin up anything
turn off anything that's the model
people say what is it'll to do the
backup the reason for elastic scale I
say is you can start with just one
virtual machine subscribe for the Haiku
service start with just one virtual
machine laid out we get comfortable and
then expand it to all your other
projects that is something you can do
the good thing you can even turn down
any of the stuff and we will only charge
you similar to Google again you only
charge you for just the things computed
use that particular day so that's it's a
very second very aligned with the Google
philosophy there the third thing when we
actually started building our solution
obviously our engineers have worked on
many different products over ten years
so we asked them guys what should we do
differently in the space apart from
being cloud and the cloud benefits they
said guys we got to make it simple and
intelligent that's what they said and
that is has been a big focus for us
that's one of the reason to get up and
running out loud to hear lubos ops
experience from Santiago but I'll tell
you it's extremely easy to get it up and
running and that's something we pride on
there's no agents or configuration any
of that stuff which is required there so
the simplicity itself we got to extend
it even to all the user management let's
say what do I mean by that
so we are fully integrated into the
Google's Identity Management I'm
assuming all of you guys all of you guys
the google customers here I'm sure all
of you guys set up your infrastructure
and your users and atom privileges in
Google I am the good thing is that once
you set up in Google I am and there's
nothing you got to do in haiku haiku
automatically inherits all of the setup
you have actually done there so there is
no extra management the reason this is
actually important when you guys decided
to move to the cloud your people who are
managing your infrastructure
predominantly a server and application
people are the ones who move to the
cloud you don't carry a backup
administrator to the cloud very rarely
do you do that right so that's one of
the reasons we wanted to make sure it's
simple and it is
bill for the cloud admin and it is for
Bill for people who are actually the
regular users of the cloud
infrastructure not necessarily a backup
administrator it's a fundamental
philosophy thing but that is something I
think will make your life lot more
easier in the longer run so the thing
also we talked about is that from a
infrastructure perspective you know once
you decided to Google you are actually
building we wanted to make sure our
entire even billing is integrated your
Google so that's when you look at your
as I said it's in backup is an extension
of your platform right so you wanted to
make sure it's fully there and it is
something you will actually see it in
haiku when you use haiku some of the
other things I wanted to probably
mention is that I talked to you about
the elastic scale it's completely scales
out the thing about haiku is that people
sometimes ask me saying why should I
choose haiku I bring in myself I asked
him saying why did you choose Google
first I asked him question biggest
things I hear from customers is simple
scalable and secure that's what we hear
from customers some of the topics were
better mentioned earlier I said that's
exactly the reason you choose high co2
so again that's me talking so you you
know you probably are thinking that I
keep talking about marked resolution I
think I should probably hear from their
self one last thing I'll tell you but
before I actually handed off to Santiago
to give you more information I talked a
lot about the backup and how our
infrastructure is at the end of the day
you're doing backup only for recovery
purpose right so if we gotta give you a
light levels of granularity and that is
something built in into haiku you can do
a file ever folder level differ
different levels of data bases and so on
and in case you guys are using cloud
sequel we actually announced support for
cloud sequel just earlier this week so
that is something you should be I
intercept plea to let us and stop by our
booth and he can give you more
information so let me actually stop here
and actually pass it on to Santiago as
Vader said Santiago is an interesting it
was a very interesting experience
working with Santiago here they are
the partner Google partner of the year
in Latin America that's a fantastic
thing and the thing is that it's not a
partner who is actually selling it to
other customers they also are a consumer
of the service so
out here Santiago gives experience
Santiago I think you subbaiya better
thank you for the introduction my name
is Santiago I'm the CTO for neuro soft
as you guys heard we are a Mexican
Google cloud partner
we've been a mex partner for eight years
now we started with G suite a long time
ago now we've been working with GCP for
over two years we have hundreds of
clients and one characteristic of Anubis
soft is we are a really automated
company we're only 20 people and we have
over 2,000 clients we also have a great
engineering team internally so this was
getting troublesome we had many many
clients and our engineers were working
on this on having a really good backup
solution what we were doing before is we
were working with scripts we were
working with other tools we had already
talked to Google about this and we
couldn't find a way to easily solve this
problem so one day we received an email
from haikyuu we had a call and the
amazing thing was in five minutes
we had our first company set up there
was us okay we were the first ones to
work with haikyuu
and in only five minutes we had a backup
recovery a great dashboard that we could
look at customers could log in as you
said with Google's I am it was
integrated with Google billing so that
make it even easier and then we decided
ok we're going to talk to the first
customers so one customer to customer
three customers and they were all amazed
by what we could do with high Q so now
we had a point in time back up we have a
fully managed application level
integrated backup we had it securely
with a lot of flexibility and it was
reliable and so far we've implemented
doses of clients nubes off we get a new
high q-- customer
every couple days because it's a mansion
we work with hundreds of clients and so
far it's been an amazing solutionn
so after the presentation we're going to
have a little QA if you have guys have
any question I think I'm gonna hand it
over to two Bader thank you
Thank You Santiago thank you Subbaiah so
our next set of speakers are gonna be
covering our archival and RM backup use
case so with them an invite Christian
onstage who is the VP of Product
Marketing at Co he city and Hans who is
the director of platform services from
Stanford medicine so Hans runs you know
the the services reliable secure
services for Stanford for the past 13
years and we're gonna hear more about
that industry and his experience when it
comes to backup in archive so with that
and it over to you Christian right thank
you about them Co acity addresses the
problem of mass data fragmentation so
let me explain to you what is actually
mean so you probably have hundreds or
thousands of applications and you backup
those applications at that of those
applications into to your storage silos
and you probably have five six seven
different management vendors to to do
this job so all of this becomes very
complex so there's a lot of
organizational and Atty complexity in
here and then you probably take copies
of this data you probably take 10 copies
of this debt or perhaps even more for
use cases like test f and so on and so
this really increases just in efficiency
of having all of this data across the
organization and then lastly this data
now is so fragmented and dispersed
across your organization you probably
don't even know what data you have and
where you have this and so this exposes
you to compliance risks so we are
addressing this kind of problem this
problem of mass data fragmentation
a single web-scale platform which spans
the cloud but also on premises and
endpoints and what we do here we
consolidate all of this complexity in a
single platform for use cases such as
backup archiving disaster recovery and
also test f and a few other use cases
and you can also download from our
marketplace applications to address use
cases like anti ransomware
or compliance applications which can
help you to actually get more value all
of your backup data so we radically
simplify backup and recovery through the
single consolidated platform and we
provide capabilities here like policy
driven automation which allows you to
eliminate scripting and manual processes
we provide google-like search which
allows you to identify and search and
recover individual files or VMs and
lastly we do all of this by greatly
reducing a data footprint and we're
using here features like global variable
length deduplication and compression so
as I mentioned before we do this across
the cloud on-premises and endpoints but
just two days ago we launched a new
service here at Google next so it's
called cohesive cloud backup service so
this is very exciting
that's a backup as a service and
specifically it provides
enterprise-grade backup and recovery for
applications running in a Google cloud
but today we really want to focus on the
hybrid use case and also here we make it
very easy and seamless to integrate into
the Google cloud and here I would like
to hand over to hands from Google from
the Stanford Medical School thanks
Christian thanks Bader as mentioned I've
been with Stanford medicine for over 13
years that's a long time at an
organization in the bay area let me tell
you a little background as to why so the
School of Medicine has missions in
education research and
patient care and Stanford medicine is on
the forefront of digital health and
precision medicine so it's really
exciting and but Stanford's mission goes
beyond the boundaries of Stanford we
care about health care around the world
I'll just give you one example there's a
Pediatrics research team that runs a
program for the state of California
that's saving nearly a thousand lives a
year in California alone and that
program is expanding beyond California
and I'm just sitting here going okay me
and my team we do what we know how to do
the researchers do their work and get
things into clinical practice and in 20
years there will be nearly 20,000 people
alive who wouldn't have been so that's
just a really compelling mission to me
so those two things together keep me in
place helping new things happen so our
platform services team is 20 folks and
I'll tell you a little bit about more
about what we are we have about a
hundred and ten critical and important
services I mean we run hundreds of
services but there's about 110 that are
critical we have 75 distinct customer
groups and that's that's complexity
we're sort of a little nonprofit
business inside Stanford and we have
somewhere between 650 and 700 server
instances mostly virtual we have about a
hundred and twenty databases and on Prem
we manage about a quarter of a petabyte
of data so what's our problem what were
we trying to do so back up an archive is
just a critical service it's probably
the most critical service we offer we
cannot lose data we have all of the the
patients and researchers and faculty who
depend on us to keep the data safe and
secure private and available we also
with our business model have to
transparently pass costs of our archive
storage at Google on to our customer
groups at Stanford and so we have to use
lots of different Google projects that's
the easiest way for us to do that we
have all the complex
and archived needs of the large
enterprise with all the virtual machines
I mentioned we have bare-metal systems
lots of locals you know centralized
storage systems as well as lots of
different operating systems and database
technologies we maintain an aging tape
backup solution it worked but it kept
many people busy safely and securely
handling a lot of tapes and with it we
felt like we needed to do lots of full
backups all the time which really puts
load on our production system so it's
not ideal but we were waiting for the
right partner to work with our strategic
cloud partner at Google to help us move
forward and when cohesive he went GA at
Google next 2018 we started working with
them right away
so all those folks need us to have those
dependable backups and we felt like we
had to back up the cloud with the eleven
nines of durability for the storage that
Google provides that's just better than
anything we could do on Prem and I would
say that both cohesive and Google with
the encryption at rest and a transit you
know they were meeting our security
needs so cohesive provides a fully
modern backup an archived solution we
have agents where needed with our bare
metal systems but we have deep and full
integration with their virtual machine
infrastructure and direct interfacing
with our central storage solutions and
so that's that's just so many steps
forward for us and cohesive these fully
hydrated incremental backups let us do
full backups much less often much less
load on our production systems and
they're letting us use all the Google
projects we might want to use and it's
really easy and that's fantastic
the recovery of data with cohesive II is
excellent I'd say we really like the
ability to immediately recover a virtual
machine from that local storage while we
move back to normal operations and the
cloud capability is the Recovery's there
are just frankly much faster than I
would have ever expected we have about
three quarters of a petabyte now
archived on google cloud and growing i
don't also want to say that our
partnership with cohesive II I mean I
appreciate it we have a very complex
nuanced security infrastructure on prem
with like dozens of VLANs and we've had
other people we've talked to an industry
you basically say don't don't do that
that's complicated and we feel like we
have to so I appreciate that cohesive
he's helped us make that work so we're
happy with the solution we have now but
we also look to the future so cohesive
these features and security and
multi-tenancy we are looking forward to
testing letting other partners in the
School of Medicine who have systems
we're not centrally managing use our
Kochi City system right alongside us
securely and safely and that's great and
the future with possibly using hybrid
and dr solutions we've already got the
data archived out there if there was
some kind of catastrophe it would be
really great to be able to use that for
a disaster recovery solution so we'll be
testing that I'm also very interested in
the just announced very low cost long
term archive solution that Google
announced we're using cold line storage
and we think that is very cost effective
and performing very well for us but
lower cost we're very sensitive to cost
so we care a lot about that and I
appreciate that announcement that was
that was a surprise for you guys this
week thank you and I look forward to
answering any questions afterwards Thank
You Hans Thank You Christian okay
all right so now we'll talk about
disaster recovery use case and how to
leverage our partnership with actifi oh
and ATB financial also taking advantage
of that capability so on stage please
welcome Patrick who is and I can't
executive for two years at actifi oh and
covers the New England and Canada market
and I hear he's a he's a decent guy as
well so and and then matt is a from a TV
that manager of the database and
infrastructure
ATB and in his own words guys this is
his own words he's a jack of all trades
and a master of as few as he can get
away with i am so taken that so with
that I hand it off to you guys thank you
my name is Patrick I'm a decent guy I
would say but we appreciate you guys
having us here today and all attending
the session so Activia we were founded
in 2009 and we've grown into a company
who has over 3,000 customers around the
globe our partnership with Google has
grown exponentially over the past past
year especially and introduced us to
great people like Matt and the team over
here so what active vo does I'll give
you a little spiel on us and then let
Matt talk for the majority of the time
but what ex FeO does is we enable
enterprises to deliver enterprise data
as a service on Prem or in any of the
public clouds specifically focusing on
Google for a mass use case so what that
means is we really focus on three key
areas and the first one is gonna be an
incremental forever backup so active
Pheo supports a wide variety of
mission-critical applications and
databases Oracle sequel sa P Hana
my sequel Postgres etc and we're gonna
take an initial ingest of all of your
applications databases on day one then
the end-user is going to create a policy
where he tells us he wants just those
change box captured every six hours for
example and then we're gonna roll those
changes into our master copy and what
this does is it allows our second use
case disaster recovery where we actually
are allowing ATB to have our virtual
active view appliance in one region of
GCP
in replicating over to a second region
in GCP where they can actually spin up
in a disaster scenario multi terabyte
mission-critical databases in a matter
of two to three minutes so our third use
case and it kind of flows back into the
initial ingest I was talking about is
that test data management use case so
you know
Activia was founded and we thought we're
already taking these backups so why
don't we just reuse these backups that
we already have so what we allow you to
do is provision out multiple copies for
a dev test staging and QA UAT in virtual
format only taking a matter of two to
three minutes and they're all just using
the pointers to point back to our X Fe o
golden copy so they're not consuming any
additional disk space so it's great for
Matt and the team you know we were able
to help them replicate from one region
to the other for multi terabyte
databases and give them the security and
a disaster scenario to kind of you know
be back up and running in a matter of
minutes but also for their dr
capabilities test that in a protected
environment so I'm gonna turn it over to
Matt I appreciate you guys coming today
and Thank You Patrick thank you Peter
just before I get started I just want to
say or apologize to Patrick that my Blue
Jays ruined the Red Sox home opener I'm
sorry but not really sorry so thank you
everyone for coming this morning
so ETB Financial is a 5500 employee
financial institution that provides
financial services to people in the
province of Alberta so we are bounded by
you know kind of the geographical
location that we're in in late 2016 we
embarked upon transformation and as part
of this transformation we were focused
on innovation and collaboration which
led us to adopt G suite and then partner
with Google for our journey to to the
cloud so to be a DCP consumer it was
part of this it was this getting started
on the journey to GCP that made us
realized that as an SI p partner we were
going to be exposed to new technologies
HANA Sybase new to us technologies that
we were going to need
that we would benefit from a solution of
how we could back them up and protect
them excuse me so we partnered with
actifi oh because we were able to cover
our backup needs which were system state
file system backups as well as any of
the new database platforms that were
part of our journey to the cloud we were
mindful of our costs and what we really
appreciate being a leverage is the
snapshot technology that Activia
provides that allows us to use efficient
cold line discs that really helps us
manage our costs in the cloud we are
also a company that has experienced a
datacenter loss and so after having that
real life DR opportunity
ATB has put a special focus on having a
very resilient and capable dr solution
which brings us to the second part of
our partnership with that actio which is
being able to leverage their
technologies to protect us in the event
of a you know losing a region in in GCP
which I know will never happen Vader but
you know just in case we we also
appreciate the ability to test that dr
capability in a protected environment
which makes our dr exercises that much
more easy to easy to simulate and takes
much less time and manpower to do and so
while our GCP landscape right now is
still fairly small it's growing quickly
and what we've appreciated is the
scalability and the ease with which
we've been able to expand our sky
appliances add sky appliances so it
means that we don't have to over
provision to start which are which the
people who do let the money at a TV
really appreciate yeah so I mean that's
that's it for me so I please I would be
happy to answer our talk or any
questions and I'll pass it back to Bader
thank you thank you guys so much
appreciate it
all right home stretch it's the last day
it's the last part of this count the
conversation here hopefully you now have
a bit more insight into the different
use cases for data protection in google
cloud from hearing from our partners and
customers today so to wrap it up you
know today we've discussed how data is
continuing to grow and how cloud backup
as an opportunity is is a growing
requirement and how you can leverage
Google cloud as an extension of your
business continuity strategy for backup
archive and disaster recovery again
helping you you know leveraging the
capabilities that we have that we spoke
about to lower your RTO and RPO s as
well as you know leverage that the
innovation the security reliability and
again that planet-scale
infrastructure and differentiation that
we bring in we're extending to you our
our customers and partners as you saw we
have anacs-- arge Data Protection
partnership ecosystem and it continues
to grow and they bring those integral
components from a data protection
perspective enabling those bad there use
cases this is not a term that we're
gonna kind though so we look to to
leverage again Google cloud as you know
this is a different cloud as you heard
this week our theme is Google cloud is
that differ is a different kind of cloud
and it will allow organizations
basically to focus we want to allow you
to focus on you're growing your business
and less about administering and running
all these legacy keep you know from a
backup into our perspective
capabilities leveraging the cloud to go
and do backup do disaster recovery and
you know let us Google cloud and our
cloud and our cloud partners to take
care of those data protection needs
[Music]